who's the greatest drummer that ever
lived beside yourself Trey I mean I'm G
to piss off a lot of people when I say
Ringo Star just because I adore him I
love Keith Moon John Bonham buddy and
Meg white and Buddy Rich of course what
about uh Ginger Baker yeah he's good but
Ringo is a surprising answer because
people Ringo wasn't a show booer he
didn't like uh maybe it wasn't the
fanciest thing but he held the beat and
it he played what supposed to played in
the song You Know drummers forget that
they're playing a song Sometimes you
know you think that drummers sometimes
have to show off the drum as opposed to
supporting the song yeah I think it's
it's probably because we're like hiding
behind the symbols and we kind you know
we don't get to wag our dongs in in
everyone's faces yeah